. We have a new report out from Goldman Sachs.
The report is shocking.
A lot of people and I don't know why the report
says that if Biden wins and there is a blue
wave in the Senate, if there is a big picture,
blue wave led by Joe Biden defeating Donald
Trump.
Goldman Sachs says it would lead to a surge
in economic growth.
And I see people acting all my.
Oh, my.
A Democrat.
It would be good for the economy, Bill.
I'm so shocked.
No.
If you've watched my show for a while, you
would already know why Democratic presidents
are better for the economy.
Goldman wrote in a note yesterday that Democratic
control of the presidency and of Congress
would raise the probability of a fiscal stimulus
package worth at least two trillion dollars.
But it's not just that longer term spending
measures that Joe Biden wants, like infrastructure,
climate, health care, education that boosts
economic growth prospects, according to Goldman
Sachs.
Assuming that the Federal Reserve doesn't
mess with interest rates until we get back
to full employment and inflation just above
two percent.
Goldman Sachs estimates that, quote, the net
effect of the Biden package would be a front
loaded increase, as well as a more backloaded
boost to core p.c inflation.
Now, Goldman is also being upfront that if
Biden is successful, for example, in raising
the corporate income tax rate from 21 to 28,
maybe that wouldn't be so good for markets
and for the economy.
There is debate there, but would that even
get passed?
It really depends on what happens in the Senate
now.
On the positive side, Goldman also says if
we get a blue wave in November, we will likely
have easier U.S. fiscal policy or renew a
reduced risk of trade escalation and a firmer
global growth outlook.
We call it stability when Donald Trump is
gone.
But none of this should surprise you because
the country does better economically under
Democratic presidents.
I talked about this 15 years ago.
I talked about it 10 years ago.
I talked about it five years ago.
I talked about it in June.
This is not about whether Democratic presidents
are left enough or really progressive or what.
This is merely about looking at a totality
of indicators.
When you have a Democratic president versus
a Republican president and it's better under
Democrats.
So why would it be any different under Joe
Biden?
Let's look at those metrics.
Typically, we would look at GDP growth.
Unemployment, stock market performance.
Then there's other intangibles like respect
around the world, you can look at poverty,
inflation, different elements.
Stock market, average annualized return when
you have a Democratic president is fourteen
point three percent.
It is ten point eight percent under Republicans.
The stock market does about 40 percent better
under Democratic presidents.
But that's not the economy.
What about GDP, gross domestic product through
2008?
Real GDP grew faster under Democratic administrations
than Republican four point one versus two
point seven.
If you were to extend those numbers to today,
Barack Obama had better GDP numbers than Donald
Trump.
So it remains GDP and stocks better with a
Democratic president.
What about income growth while under Democrats?
Real median income over the last 50 years
grew at two point two percent per year under
Republicans only point six percent.
So there you've got wages on the flip side.
Unemployment has been 18 percent higher under
Republican presidents since World War two
job creation.
Democratic presidents have seen 24 million
more jobs created on their watch, with an
average of 78 percent more jobs created per
year of a Democratic administration than during
a Republican administration.
Bloomberg looked at U.S. job creation and
found that for the close to half century following
the Kennedy administration.
Democrats have created.
Wait for it.
Nearly twice as many private sector jobs as
Republicans.
Even though Democrats have had the presidency
for five fewer years during that time, none
of this is new and none of this is news.
This is the reality.
And we see Republicans maintain almost a monopoly
on the reputation of being good for the economy.
How many Republican governors have actually
destroyed state budgets?
Look at what happened in Kansas.
But if you've been following the data, you
would know that this is merely a lie.
And even on economy, Trump's numbers are worse
compared to Biden's than most Republicans.
Again, there's this idea that Republicans
are better for the economy.
They are not.
When they say Republicans are good for the
economy, what they mean is Republicans will
cut regulations and it will it will allow
companies to make money by polluting companies
to make money, by taking advantage of the
environment, taking advantage of employees.
That lets the very rich get slightly richer.
But it's not so good for the economy overall.
When Republicans say we're good for the economy
because of small government, they mean we
will cut education and we will cut welfare,
but we will keep writing blank checks to the
military budget will pay farmers to grow nothing
or to destroy crops.
And we will continue this failed idea of what
it means to run an economy.
It is all horrible code.
It's a moral code for really bad policies
that help the very rich but aren't so good
for everybody else.
It's great that Goldman Sachs put out this
report, but it's not actually newsworthy because
if you've been paying attention for the last
however many years, you would know that this
is a false notion that Republicans are great
for the economy.
We'll have some of the data I mentioned today
on our Instagram page.
OK, so make sure you're following us on Instagram
at David Pakman show.
And while you're there, follow me on Instagram
for a break from politics.
It's Poppy's books.
And what else?
I don't know a lot of that on my Instagram.